oh
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
may all look very familiar to you
this is samsung galaxy s9 uh yeah this
is definitely s9 and uh this is new
you're probably wondering if it's worth
your money for an upgrade you may also
just be wondering if it's a good phone
or not so i think the best way to
describe this phone is it's a nearly
perfect
samsung phone so what i mean by that is
if you've liked samsung phones in the
past or you have an old samsung phone
and you like what they do with the
software with the great cameras with the
awesome design with their build
then this is the best and most complete
version of that that they've ever made
but conversely if you already don't like
samsung phones like if slow android
updates aren't your thing or you just
don't like what they do with the skin
then this isn't going to change your
mind so it's a nearly perfect
samsung phone so last year the galaxy s8
had the infiniti display this year again
galaxy s9 has one of the absolute best
displays in any smartphone sandwiched
between even slightly thinner top and
bottom bezels than last time and they've
even done a slightly better job hiding
the sensors and things in that top bezel
so the black looks more seamless and
that earpiece also now doubles as a
second speaker front-facing speaker so
you kind of have a bit of a stereo
speaker thing going on here it's not
quite the same obviously as two big
dedicated front-facing speakers but at
least now it's a bit louder and clearer
if you accidentally block the bottom
speaker which can happen you don't
completely miss what's going on so it's
better last year you also had usbc and
wireless charging fast charging all that
that is also all still here usbc
fast charging wireless charging a
headphone jack water resistance is great
clicky buttons and just overall a plus
build quality now it's still glass which
means you're still going to get smudges
so if you want to pick up a dbrand skin
this new black camo might not make your
phone invisible but it'll make all the
smudges and scratches disappear and then
the biggest change on the outside has to
be obviously the fingerprint reader
placement it's now in the middle instead
of up at the top next to the camera and
that makes a huge difference even more
than people are giving it credit for
it's perfect now it's raised slightly so
it's easy to know when your fingers on
it when you're not looking at it and
registering your fingerprint is now just
a slow swipe like you roll your finger
down the scanner once
which is actually really cool i thought
it was a glitch usually you kind of you
know you have to press it on the
fingerprint reader a whole bunch of
times to enroll your finger but during
this phone setup you just roll your
finger down at once and it's a hundred
percent done that is awesome and then
there's also now on the back of this
phone a blood pressure sensor in
addition to the heart rate monitor so
the heart rate monitor is not new we've
had that for a while you can measure
your heart rate that's quick but the
blood pressure sensor usually you
haven't been able to do that with
anything other than like the wrap and
the tools in the doctor's office to
actually get that reading in that number
i wasn't able to get that reading with s
health or any of the health apps on my
phone but i like a really good video
from dave2d on how exactly this works
there's a certain way to get it to help
you if you do want to use this phone to
measure blood pressure
but as of right now it's just a pretty
cool new addition last year's galaxy s8
also had top-notch specs when it came
out s9 here keeps that up and bumps it
up too again for 2018. snapdragon 845
and four or six gigs of ram and this
does definitely feel like the smoothest
samsung phone yet it still doesn't match
stock android you know there's still
little performance hiccups like when
opening up bixby for example and
occasionally and some other samsung apps
uh but in my couple of weeks with this
phone that's about it everything else
nearly matches pixel 2 and smoothness
and i'm really happy about that and then
there is all the samsung software uh
again they're still really not shy about
their colorful look on top of android so
it's not going to change your mind if
you already dislike the samsung stuff
but it's all better it still has a ton
of advanced features it added iris
scanning from the note which is a little
slower but more secure than regular
facial recognition using the
front-facing camera and there's also a
new intelligent scan which combines face
scanning and iris scanning basically
using which one works better depending
on light conditions so i'm really into
the new fingerprint reader so i haven't
necessarily used these as much but it's
cool to have all the options it still
has a bunch of samsung's big screen
tricks and app shortcuts you still get
the edge shortcuts and some more
customization options with those
sometimes with all the stuff it can feel
like samsung is just kind of dumping as
many features as possible on you and
maybe they are but that's part of what
they do it still has bixby and the bixby
button and everything bixby's good for
okay i could have just disabled the
bixby button from day one i know that
but i decided to give it another chance
i've left it enabled since day one every
day using bixby and it's still not that
great not only have i triggered it a
couple times on purpose but many times
by accident when taking it out of my
pocket and every time i open it i just
kind of scroll down hoping to find
something useful in these cards
uh but usually i don't so then i close
it bixby voice can still do a lot of
those like really intricate digging into
the settings and longer strings of
commands in the phone that other
assistants can't do as well so that's
pretty cool so uh
turn on the flashlight
so if you're into that if that's
something you do on your phone often
you'll like bixby when it understands
you
but i'm not that person so i'm gonna go
ahead and disable it for now so yeah
this is clearly still unapologetically a
samsung phone
in a software department for better or
for worse there's still two browsers out
the box two smart assistants two
calendars two messaging apps all the
classic half-hearted samsung ecosystem
push is still there but it's also
android so you can get rid of that stuff
that's annoying if you don't want it
battery life i think is the biggest
weakness of these new phones the s9 and
s9 plus it's not terrible but among all
the other great things about these
phones the battery life is definitely
not great so i spend most of my time
with the s9 plus which has the bigger
screen but also bigger battery 3 500
milliamp hours
and it would be dead by the end of the
day and most of my heavy use days with a
lot of navigation a lot of music playing
a lot of screen on time watching videos
and social media that would be enough to
kill this phone in a single day i don't
even do that much mobile gaming but if i
were that would kill it too the upside
of that as it always is with samsung is
fast charging and wireless charging it
charges really fast with the right
charger the one in the box of course uh
or one of several other usbc chargers
like the macbook pro charger but it can
be kind of picky the dash charger for
example didn't work if you're curious
but being able to top up really quickly
during the day for me i've said this
before it does offset the slightly weak
battery this phone has it would be great
if it had better battery but for me
that's good enough depends on who you
are
and then for
the biggest most
reimagined new change in these phones
that would be the camera let's break
that down so there's a new 12 megapixel
camera on the back and if you get the s9
plus it gets the second telephoto camera
as well and it's the first modern
smartphone with a variable aperture
camera it can physically switch between
f 1.5 and f 2.4 depending on your
lighting so it defaults to f 2.4 which
is roughly average for a smartphone
camera actually and that's for your
sharp normal daylight photos most of the
time when you do get to low light under
100 lux that's when it's going to switch
to wide open f 1.5 technically speaking
the mechanism to do this is really
impressive
but it only matters if you can see the
difference in photos so
does it make a difference so alright
generally photos from the galaxy s9
camera are pretty damn good photos are a
little bit less over processed and a
little less over sharpened than they
used to be but it's clearly still the
samsung look we're used to with the
bright vibrant colors dynamic range i'd
say is the most noticeable improvement
but that's something they've actively
worked on so it's good to see something
you'll notice looking through all of
these though is samsung's tendency to
overexpose
still pretty much every photo i take on
the galaxy s9 in auto mode
is just a little bit too bright it's
just just a little bit but then it can
also be a sort of an advantage when you
take it to low light galaxy s9 low light
photos look pretty good and that really
is thanks to the f 1.5 aperture letting
in way more light so the question of is
this variable aperture making a
difference well low light shots have
seen a real bump up there's less
smoothing because it gets rid of less
grain because there's less grain because
there's more light being led into the
camera so fundamentally yes it's working
it's still not the best camera in any
smartphone though that's still pixel 2
hands down and i'd say it still falls a
little bit behind iphone 10 but i don't
think anyone will be disappointed with
the third place performance of a great
galaxy s9 camera something people have
also noticed recently is it shoots video
in the rec 2020 color space instead of
rec 709 that's what happens when you
turn on or leave on hdr if you turn that
off they can be rec 709 so it's trying
to look better again and more saturated
on the samsung displays but you can turn
that off so all right back in the
impressions video i did mention that it
seems like galaxy s9 plus will have a
pretty big advantage over the regular
galaxy s9 because you're getting now
more ram
more screen
more battery and more camera so it turns
out most of this isn't actually that big
of a deal in the more ram department yes
galaxy s9 plus has six gigs of ram while
the regular s9 has four gigs of ram both
are plenty hardly ever gonna notice the
difference in regular everyday use could
be nice for future proofing though the
s9 plus obviously has the second
telephoto camera for live focus and for
optical zoom sometimes may or may not
ever use that if you do obviously go
with s9 plus but you might not miss that
and then of course the size difference
means your 5.8 inch display versus 6.2
inch and then your 3000 to 3500 milliamp
hour battery again both of which are
somewhat mediocre so not a huge
difference between them so it's a toss
up if you're choosing between them but i
think the biggest thing i got out of
this galaxy s9 plus existing now at this
price point is there's way less reason
to buy a galaxy note 8 right now the
note 8 is really all about the stylus
and it comes in at about a thousand
bucks i would definitely pick the s9
plus over that because of the lower
price even though you get a slightly
smaller screen all the same advantages
are there if you don't use that stylus
and even a lot of the other reasons
people might have gone towards the
galaxy note in the past like your media
experience the huge screen this tends to
do a lot of that just as good if not
better since you also get stereo
speakers but that's just if you're
picking between samsung phones my point
from the beginning of the video stands
this is just about the optimal
samsung phone that you can get right now
with all the pros and cons that come
with that you get all the pros and up
sides of the samsung experience taken to
the max the awesome displays the a plus
build quality the checking of pretty
much every box stereo speakers headphone
jack expandable storage and a pretty
damn good camera but you also get all
the cons of the samsung experience too
your double apps your slower android
updates your occasional hiccups
bixby so this thing really is great it's
perfect for the samsung lover but i as
you probably already know am not that
person i will be switching back i think
to my pixel 2 as a daily so with the
galaxy s9 it makes it really easy to
under appreciate it because it seems
like you know oh it's just a minor
upgrade it's not that much better it's
like an s8s and you could say it's a
jack of all trades but the master of
none
but that's actually what makes this
phone so good first of all it is the
master of one the display there isn't
really any better than this but it's
actually so good at so many different
things and bad at so few things
especially being so good at the hardware
suite that's what makes this phone so
easy to recommend
and so i do i recommend the galaxy s9
it's really good so either way that's
been it thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]